I thought I'd leave it, but
I'm just cheating like that. I'm not
going to make any progress. Pero, I'm going to make excuses for the rest of my life.
Hey,
it might be awful to hit the punch. Oh, it's in my
mother's butt.
If it
hits, but it doesn't work at all, then if I hit it
again, I wouldn't think I could have won.
Porto  I don't know
what it is, I'm
proud of it Tsuki
par
tar Yeah
yeah
I think I'm in it
Ah ah ah ah
[music]
ah ah ah ah ah
divorce
[music]
ah
ah ah  But now,
even using me detection, what should I do with Jacob? How can I make a
shakura? It
's one of you in the star seat. I could have done without Sakura.
Decided
[Music] For the
first time, a person was able to communicate with Rokudo Hibari.